-It's so great to see you. Thank you for coming back.
-Thanks for allowing us back.
-The last time we were all together was, like,
summer of 2020, I want to say.
-I remember summer of 2020.
-♪ It was the summer of ♪
-2019. -2019. It was 2019.
-In person. In person.
-Because we went on a boat, like, in 2020.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. -Remember? Karamo threw up?
It was a whole thing. -That's right. Karamo.
Yeah, by the way, he's not here tonight.
We will say -- -Because he's throwing up again.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. -He's feeling a little --
He's not gonna risk it.
-[ Overlapping dialogue ] -We love you. We love him.
-Let's go through all of you, because we had --
A lot of things have happened since you've all been here together.
Tan, you've become a father.
-Yeah!
-Little bitty baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My little baby Ismael. I was shocked that --
Well, we got so close that --
Jonathan carried my child for me, which was really sweet.
[ Talking over each other ]
-The bounce-back was real heavy.
-No, you did such a good job with the labor.
Thank you so much. -Yeah.
-Yeah. Ismael.
And he is 6 months old, and he is just --
I love him so much.
-Can I just tell you how --
This is so real of a dad, of a new dad.
I was backstage saying hi to you maybe not even two seconds.
You're showing me pictures of the baby.
-I know. I'm sorry.
-You've become that guy. -I'm obsessed.
-Isn't he the cutest, though?
-He's so juicy. Oh, he's so cute.
-He honestly is, in my opinion, the cutest baby you'll ever see.
But he really is. He's gorgeous. -Yeah, yeah.
Jonathan, you announced that you're married.
-What? -Yeah!
-Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Jonathan! -I did it. I did it, I did it.
-Wait, wait. What -- How -- Are you loving married life?
-It is really so much fun.
He's, obviously, stunning.
And, yeah, I'm, like, married and it's, like, really fun.
And who knew? -I knew.
-Wait. Well, you knew. -You knew. You knew.
-Well, who knew? Like, you know, who knew?
-Who knew that you could find --
-We were the first, actually.
-Well, you guys did. Yeah, they did.
But I just mean, like, little me.
You know, I grew up in a time when, like,
marriage equality wasn't a thing.
And so I'm so happy that I get to be on this journey
and get to share my life with someone who is so hot.
And it's just so much fun.
-Quick question. Update. How are the cats, by the way?
-Oh, my gosh. Everyone's thriving.
All five. Everyone's good. -And the chickens.
Liza Meownelli's IBS has finally settled down.
So we're thriving over there.
-I really can't wait for that kids show
'cause you have to do that.
-Bobby, you did something that not many people can say.
You were on "The Masked Singer."
-I was a pig --
-A caterpillar on "The Masked Singer."
-He was so good. -It was great.
-Thank you, thank you!
And the largest costume in "Masked Singer" history
and the heaviest and also the hottest.
I think it was about 120 degrees in there.
The first performance, I about passed out.
The second performance, I learned to have them
put me in an ice vest,
and it was completely packed with ice.
It was the best. I'm going to wear them now
when we film in the hottest states in America next season.
-I have a question. How come when you're performing
everyone always has to put you in the hottest suit ever?
When you did "Lip Sync Battle," you were in Britney's
red latex suit. Now you're in a caterpillar.
-♪ Ooh ♪ -Who's got it out for you?!
-It's true, it's true.
And I'm always the one that's the hottest.
-But you were so great. -Thank you. Thank you.
-I feel like the competition was a little, you know --
You should've won. I'm gonna say it, America.
You heard it here first. -Wow!
-Thank you. Thank you. -We want a recount.
-There's a hanging chad.
-The crazy thing about that show is how real it is.
Like, I assumed -- I'm like,
"There's no way anyone's singing in one of those costumes."
It's pre-recorded, and you're just --
No, you really do sing live.
-How secretive is it, though? -No.
When I get out of the car, I have to have a full mask on,
gloves on, socks on. They don't even want to see your ankles.
Only like three producers
and obviously network executives know who you are.
Even backup dancers didn't know. Other contestants didn't know.
Like, I was standing there at one point holding Jewel's hand
and I didn't know! And I love her!
-It was Jewel? I love her.
"Foolish Games" is one of the greatest songs of all time.
-"Pieces of You," the whole album
got me through my whole adolescence.
-Antoni, it's always good to see you.
Rocking a nice watch as always. Which one is that one?
-Tonight we are featuring a 1952 Constellation Omega.
-Oh, my gosh. Always gorgeous.
Can I just ask about -- -[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
-Can I just talk about this? Because --
Everyone on the Internet is talking about this.
On the show, out of nowhere, let's just say,
there's little bumpers, there's things, there's action shots.
You rescued a dog. -I did.
-Congratulations. -Thank you so much.
-Neon. -Neon the Mutt,
if you want to follow her on socials.
-Yeah. Okay. Good.
-She's a lovely, lovely Pit rescue
from a really great organization in Austin
called Austin Pets Alive! where you also adopted.
They really do God's work.
-There was something that we saw on the show
that everyone was, like, talking about
probably because of the dog, I'm assuming.
-Absolutely. -Yeah.
-Yeah, here's a photo of you washing the dog.
Yeah, so, clearly --
-I like how she's staring right at his belly button.
[ Applause ]
-It was a very hot day!
-Oh, really? He's was a masked caterpillar!
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
We need to talk "Queer Eye" because, man, oh, man.
Always -- You know I love the show.
And I'm not just saying that.
And the first episode always gets me.
And I go, "Oh, yeah."
But this one really, really got me
because when you started filming,
it was right before the pandemic.
-Yeah. -So you were in Austin, Texas.
You're filming. It's an amazing story.
Moving. And then there's no end.
Like, Tan, what was going down?
-You know, we went into this thinking, "Yeah, maybe
the pandemic isn't gonna really take off in the U.S.
and we'll just go shoot the show."
And then, literally, a few days later, we had just finished --
You know when we do the reveal where we show them the home,
we put them in the new outfit?
We had done that.
And then we left for the weekend
and we just didn't come back for over a year.
And so this was the first time ever on "Queer Eye"
where we got to see
how our lessons were taken on by our hero.
And so a year later, we got to revisit
and how life changed so much.
She'd been through so much. -I was like -- 'Cause you go --
Sometimes you see these shows and you go like,
"Oh, yeah, they changed their life
or they changed their hair."
And then a year later, they're back to normal.
Her life actually changed, and it was just so beautiful.
You guys are gonna freak out if you haven't seen it already.
It's so cool. And it is so good.
-You're making me teary-eyed. -I love you.
-Well, because it's bittersweet.
-It's just a beautiful thing, and it's real.
And it's so awesome. The whole season is awesome.
I just want to say congrats, also.
This might be the awesomest.
You guys are officially Legos. Did you know that?
-Isn't that wild?
-My childhood dream come true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Officially. -It's so wild!
-What does that feel like? -It's pretty freaking cool.
It was my favorite toy growing up.
And -- Yeah. -I used to get in trouble before
school in the morning because I wouldn't be getting ready
for school because I'd be playing with my Lego.
-Yeah. -"Playing with my Lego."
Playing with my Lego mini figures.
-We know what you --
People are gonna step on you guys and scream to the moon.
-I was hoping -- I was hoping --
I have this fantasy that, like,
Ted Cruz's or Mitch McConnell's, like, nephew or niece
are, like, nibbling, someone's going to sneak them
a "Queer Eye" Lego set.
And then it's going to, like, fall off the table.
And, like, my Lego will be underneath one of their feet
and they'll just be like, "Ow!"
And then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm always so happy to see you guys.
There's never enough time to talk to you guys.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here are the fab five in the new season of "Queer Eye."
Take a look.
-Angel's deadlift is more than two Antonis.
She's a powerful woman.
-Is this actually a queer gym?
-Yes. Queer woman owned. Queer women ran.
-Wow!
-Ooh!
Yay!
-You're just showing off at this point.
-Two more. Hello. -Two.
-If you held this in front of me, I would, like,
really just keep -- keep coming for it.
-Keep coming for it.
-"I just want the doughnut." -"I just want the doughnut."
-Antoni Porowski, Bobby Berk, Jonathan Van Ness, Tan France.
Season six of "Queer Eye" is streaming now on Netflix.